elle traverse les cieux et elle finit
dans les airs c'est une comète entourée
de mystère méfiez vous car avant le
lever du soleil au plus noir des
ténèbres quelque chose signer
vous avez vu la comète cette nuit non
mais tu as vu cet immense boule de
lumière verte dans le ciel un comte
millénaire parle de cette mystérieuse
comète
et d'un monde de légendes yaka
sur le point d'être révélée qu'est ce
que c'est que cette chose
voilà qui est intéressant
tu as entendu surgissement un truc de ce
genre non non non moi je sais si tu
entends subi la cour les faits doivent
voler à tire d'aile et affronter tous
les dangers
tu me cache quelque chose qui moi ne dit
pas le contraire
je connais ce regard j'ai inventé ce
regard pour changer le destin de la
vallée des fées bon d'accord d'accord
mais promet de ne pas hurler je vais pas
parler et se faire un ami pour la vie tu
m'avait pourtant dit que c'était quelque
une légende on pourrait presque actes
j'ai dit qu'il n'était pas celui qu'on
croit
ça pourrait menacer la balle est tout
entier mais si tu le trouves tu feras
quoi mon travail
allez franchement et que je vous ai déjà
mise en danger
j'en ai un club de d1 campagne
zaz ressemble à celui d'un temps je re
prédateurs noah toujours eu grand coeur
voilà tout
on a beaucoup
et
pour une fois ma tête et mon coeur me
dit de faire la même chose
disney présente clochait si la créature
légendaire tu es une sorte de croisement
entre le divertissement social iste une
piste en occident tanit
il crache un sikh très mauvais
moralement ce ensemble